all right let's get to hatred mail i'll
remind you
what hatred mail is especially if you've
never heard it before
the right of the people to keep and bear
hate
shall not be infringed
mail written by patriots who hate david
pakman
because america and because
freedom this week's patriot mail has a
lot of the buzz words that we are common
in trumpian language let's take a listen
and see if we can make heads or tails
out of it
david pakman and his little fans are all
just
jealous losers get jobs losers
get back to community college where you
belong davey and do your stupid little
show there
maybe at community college you can take
some speech therapy lessons to help with
that gay list
losers like you have never worked a day
in your worthless lives
loser like you live in mommy's basements
and collect free obama bucks
because you're victims and entitled
okay get to your safe space
snowflake it's weird because this isn't
like a safe space special snowflake
trigger warning show it's sort of weird
that someone would criticize
us for that it's almost like they don't
even really understand
what the show is about when they write
to me and the whole community college
thing
if the critique is the show should be
broadcast out of a community college we
once shared space with a community
college it was a great space i mean
there's nothing to be embarrassed about
there
and if the thing is i should go back
because i as an individual
should get a community college degree or
something i mean like i have a master's
degree i don't know what the implication
is there that i'm not educated
but i guess i'm trying to maybe read too
much into it yeah you probably are and
unfortunately for this viewer i mean
the show is doing well regardless of
whether or not he agrees with what we're
saying
and regardless of whether we're still at
a community college or not rachel which
i know what by the way what's wrong with
community college anyway
i there's absolutely nothing wrong with
it i think it's completely
wonderful i don't know if they're trying
to use that as some sort of
underhanded insult yeah backhanded
insult
it's very very odd but at the same time
a lot of these hatreds think that
higher education is liberal
indoctrination anyway so it's a very
very
inconsistent criticism there's some
stigma i think attached with community
college that might not hold the
same reputation as a private liberal
arts institution so maybe in that way it
could be used as
an insult but it's an education is an
education it's a pretty flaccid critique
i would say yeah all right remember you
can use
coupon code hatred 40 to get a major
discount off of your membership at
davidpakman.com
membership turn hatred mail and
patriotism
into something good for independent
media